- Well, it seems like just
after I release a video
on the controversy of
the Nike versus MSCHF,
the Satan shoes trademark case, well,
the parties just up and settled,
so this case is really no more.
As part of the settlement,
at least the part that's public,
Nike says that MSCHF will recall the shoes
and offer a full reimbursement
to anyone that purchased the
shoes and wants a refund.
But other than that, it doesn't seem
that the parties agreed
to any other terms.
So it doesn't seem like MSCHF
is going to have to pay Nike
anything, which of course
is a great result for MSCHF
because they got tons
and tons of publicity
which is of course what they
wanted in the first place.
So it doesn't look like
we'll see Nike or MSCHF
in the same court again,
but I will see you in court.